with sub GQ I'm Lisa Torres I'm a barber
stylist and hair expert and today we're
gonna break down some of the most iconic
celebrity braid hairstyles
[Music]
ASAP Rocky is very well known for having
box braids it's a style that was very
popular in the 90s and it's extremely
relevant today a box braid essentially
is known for having a square parting and
the hair is braided directly off of it a
lot of people like to wear in a ponytail
they like to wear it in their face very
very popular amongst men and women
depending on the amount of braids you
want and the size they can be anywhere
from an hour to like eight hours I think
this style on ASAP it looks really good
it's very stylish a phenomenal hairstyle
for most people and it looks great on
him it's funny how I feel like not
everyone can pull off wearing letters in
their hair I feel like the way he does
is that he makes sure that he brings the
culture of the streets into fashion I
think I like the G in the back of his
head better just because this is bigger
it makes it easier for the the braider
to create the actual shape when it's
small it's a little trickier I think
that he has has a great face and head
shape if he ever decided to not have
braids but I don't think anybody in the
world could imagine him without braids
so Travis Scott who is also very well
known for having box braids he wears
them a little different he has the
hairline taper which is essentially that
you take the hair that is would make up
the front hairline and it's shaved off
to match the hair on the side with a
small island of hair long hair where
it's braided and he likes to wear big
box braids so that's more like jumbo box
braids so this haircut suits him really
well because he loves to wear his braids
in his face and it's really easy for him
to move around like the rock star that
he is I'm Team all black but that might
be a little bit of a bias because Styles
come and go so right now I think I'm
leaning more towards the natural
hairstyle natural hair color
[Music]
little yachty is very well known for
having these bright red small box braids
with the beads and I think it was a
really cool hairstyle was a really cool
way to bring it back to the younger
demographic so to put these beads on the
braids you have to use a special tool it
kind of looks like a giant needle you
kind of fill it up with the beads and
then the opening you you put the braid
in and then you slide the beads up into
the braid now that it's been a couple
years I feel like this style has aged
well I feel like when he did it it was
more simple so nowadays the the beads
tend to be more intricate more colorful
but it held the test of time and people
are still getting beads on their hair
[Music]
for the hairstyle
that right she jumbo box braids and then
for the style on the left she has small
box braids they're not considered micro
but they're pretty small there's a lot
of them there but for the jumbo box
braids this is like a super easy
hairstyle it looks like she could have
some extensions but as you can see it's
harder to tell it Blends in very well
with her natural hair it's it's a cute
more like natural look
I feel like it's definitely doable to
wear braids straight backs extensions
all of that with a beautiful gown this
one is super beautiful the one thing
about braids that most people who aren't
in the hair world or may not be as
exposed to is to understand how
beautiful and elegant
braids can be
[Music]
so nipsy hustle is very well known for
his simple four braid straight backs
they're considered Like A variation of a
straight back the lines and the partings
are essentially straight back but the
braid in the front instead of starting
in the middle starts at a point
and this is why this specific style is
called the nipsy braids because they
have that specific element
cornrows and straight backs tend to come
off as the same thing but a straight
back is essentially the braid is
starting from the front of the head and
it's going only straight back to the
back of the head whereas a cornrow could
either be starting in the middle coming
off to the side or even a design can be
considered a cornrow it's just the hair
being braided on the head he definitely
popularized it because he was so
consistent and I don't even think other
than two braids I've ever seen him wear
any other hairstyle
[Music]
I think that when Drake got braids it
shocked the world but I think that he
did it the best way he has a phenomenal
grader and he also kept his braids very
simple and I think that testing the
waters when you're not sure if braids
are going to look good on you always
start with something simple and work
your way up to more complicated
intricate Styles the two braids on Drake
looks the most stylish the four and six
braids tend to blend in and look a
little normal on him but the two braids
because he specifically got them like on
the crown of his head and the super
Sleek slickness of it is different like
people aren't doing that right now it's
like the Snoop Dogg braids but nobody's
stinky Snoop Dogg they're thinking Drake
like wow they look great on you with two
braids I think it goes further for him
[Music]
so pop smoke has cornrows and he
popularized the starting from the middle
bringing it to the side and off the head
some people don't know if they should
call this a box braid which is often a
question but this is a cornrow for sure
this hairstyle looks really good on him
because he also kind of has like a small
face so to bring to bring the braids
down it kind of creates like a face
frame a little bit and like elongates
the space it's just designed to work for
him and the popularity behind it made it
iconic
[Applause]
most people when they think of Rihanna's
brace they think of the Fulani braids
which is the hair being braided on the
scalp corn rolled essentially up to like
about half the head and then the hair in
the back is box braids which are off the
head so most people like her braids when
it comes to the Fulani Styles just
because they're more wearable and not
too many people actually rock it in the
celebrity world
so who doesn't know Iris and braids he's
very famous for having designs designs
that specifically have many braids in
them the zigzag braids The Fish Bone
braids he was
Beyond iconic for for his style and
everything that he's done is relevant
today and I think will be relevant
tomorrow all right guys well that's all
we have for today and if there's anyone
that we miss make sure that you put it
in the comments below and maybe we'll
get to them next time
foreign foreign